What are some general things that somebody can do for cancer?
So if I diagnose with cancer, some general things that you want to look at is
simply start with cleaning up your diet because it's dietary factors that cause of cancer.
Well, no, not usually. Sometimes, yes.
But cleaning up your diet is going to be the best thing to help stimulate your immune system.
Obviously, you have cancer. If I'm diagnosed with cancer, what I'm doing up to this point is not working to get rid of it.
Otherwise, I wouldn't be diagnosed with it.
So you've got to look at, though, maybe it's not the causative factor or maybe it's not going to make a giant difference.
But certainly looking at diet, cleaning up too much excess sugar in your diet, cleaning up too much excess animal proteins in your diet,
dairy is a big driver because of the growth factors in dairy.
Just doing some simple things to clean up your diet is a good thing to do.
That's going to help your body be able to, your immune system be able to attack the cancer instead of dealing with inflammatory responses because of maybe poor dietary habits.
So that would be one thing to do. For a nutritional standpoint, my book is filled with different options
as far as different supplements to take. So I'd probably refer you to look at that.
And again, that's a free download on the website, so I'm not trying to sell you anything.
So go on our website, connersclinic.com, to the book section of the blog section, you can download a free copy of the book.